I want you to imagine two paintings.
They were painted in the same year in
the same city.
They used the same pigments and depicted
the same subject matter.
One of these paintings hangs in a
climate-controlled vault in Paris or New
York. It's insured for a hundred million
dollars.
It's a masterpiece. It sits among the
Picassos, the Matisses, the Georgia
O'Keeffes, and the Salvador Dalís.
These are works that seem to transcend
paint on canvas. They have become
something eternal.
The other painting? It's currently
languishing in a basement in North
Carolina or maybe in a thrift store bin
priced at $5.
It's been forgotten. When you look at
two works of art, it's not always clear
what makes one so valuable while another
is discarded. Is it pure luck? Is it
just about who the artist knew or which
rich patron decided to buy it?
Here's a strange thing, though. We say
beauty is in the eye of the beholder,
that there's no accounting for taste.
But if art is subjective,
how is it so many people agree that some
paintings are masterpieces? For a
painting to truly become famous over
decades, lots and lots of people need to
agree that it's a masterpiece. Are they
just sheep following one another? Or is
it possible that there are specific
combinations of color and texture that
make paintings evocative and memorable,
specific things that can make a painting
a masterpiece? Is it possible there is a
formula for masterpieces?
Today, I'm going to share with you a
powerful idea. The place to look for the
secret formula, it isn't in the
paintings. It's inside your brain.
The reason we remember some kinds of art
and forget others has to do with a set
of hidden algorithms inside the human
brain.
To understand this, I need to start
somewhere completely different. Not with
genius,
but with failure.
Let's play a game. Here are two versions
of the famous Monopoly Man.
Look closely.
Which one is the real mascot of the
popular board game?
Lock in your answer. If you pick the
version with the monocle, you're wrong.
The Monopoly Man does not have a
monocle. He never had a monocle. In
fact, he has no eyewear at all. Did you
get that wrong? Don't worry. So do lots
of people. Let's try another one.
Star Wars fans, you're up.
Here is C-3PO, the anxious droid from a
galaxy far, far away. Is he entirely
gold,
or does he have a silver leg?
If you said all gold, you're wrong
again.
C-3PO has always had a silver left leg.
But you're in good company. Lots of
people get this one wrong, too. And for
me, it was clear that he was the
completely gold one. I don't know why he
would have a silver left leg. That's
Wilma Bainbridge, a psychologist at the
University of Chicago.
One last try. Third time's the charm,
right? Here's Waldo, the guy you spent
hours searching for in that game,
Where's Waldo?
Does Waldo hold a cane,
or are his hands empty?
Lots of people say, "Yeah, Waldo doesn't
have a cane."
He does. Now, here's the fascinating
part. It's not remarkable that you made
mistakes. We all forget things. We
forget where we put our keys. I
constantly forget faces and names.
What's interesting here is that many,
many people make the same, identical
mistake. We remember a monocle that
never existed. It just feels right. This
phenomenon, where lots of people
collectively believe something that is
false, has a name.
The Mandela effect.
The Mandela effect is a term coined by
Fiona Broome. She is a paranormal
researcher. She coined this term when
she realized that she had the same false
memory as many other people about Nelson
Mandela. So, she had a false memory that
he had died in prison in the 1980s. But
he didn't. Nelson Mandela spent more
than 25 years in a South African prison
during apartheid.
But he survived it. He became president
of South Africa. He lived a long life.
Yet, large groups of people remember
news reports of his death, his funeral,
memories that are false.
Now, some people on the internet believe
this is evidence of parallel universes,
that we have slipped from one dimension
where Mandela died into another where he
lived. But Wilma had a different theory.
She suspected this wasn't about multiple
dimensions of reality.
It was about how the human mind has a
tendency to make predictable errors when
it comes to memory.
She asked herself if the same thing was
happening with the Monopoly Man and
C-3PO. She decided to call it the visual
Mandela effect. We specifically focused
on visual examples of the Mandela effect
or ways in which it's manifested in
images because you can do all these
interesting analyses on images, like
look at what people look like in the
image.
Wilma took these cultural icons into the
lab. She started with 40 different
images, the Monopoly Man, C-3PO, Fruit
of the Loom, Curious George, and she
altered them. She showed versions of the
pictures to hundreds of people to see if
people had false memories. Take the
Fruit of the Loom logo. What do you see
in your mind? A pile of fruit spilling
out of a cornucopia, a woven basket?
Most people do. But But real logo, it's
just fruit. No basket, no cornucopia.
Never has been.
Now, there are a number of possible
reasons we make these mistakes. It could
be that wrong versions of these images
are everywhere on the internet and we've
absorbed this misinformation. Or it
could be that they have mental
associations that lead them astray. A
rich old banker from the 1930s, he's got
to have a monocle, right? Wilma tested
these theories. She found they were
wrong. It turns out the brain simply has
a propensity to remember certain images.
The wrong version of the image is just
more sticky.
And that made Wilma think, is it
possible then that other images are
simply easier to remember? We like to
think that memory is personal. You
remember a face because it looks like
your mother. You remember a painting
because you saw it on your honeymoon.
Wilma argues that the scientific
evidence suggests some things are simply
more memorable. We've all seen this
firsthand. We tend to remember some
faces and forget others. We might not be
able to tell why, but lots of us
remember the same faces. They're just
more memorable. Now, you should be
jumping up and down at this point and
shouting, the reason we remember some
movie stars is because we've all seen
the same faces on the big screen. Good
point. In one of her earlier studies,
Wilma addressed this problem by building
a massive database of over 10,000
ordinary faces. She showed them to
thousands of people and she found
something stunning. So there were some
faces that
everyone just remembered and there were
some faces that everyone just forgot. Do
we remember beautiful faces? Not
necessarily. Wilma found that
attractiveness had a weak connection to
memorability. In fact, being beautiful
can make you more likely to be confused
with somebody else.
Do we remember some faces because they
convey certain emotions? Wilma did find
that looking irresponsible
made you slightly more memorable, but it
only explained a tiny fraction of the
data. Instead, there seemed to be an X
factor, a hidden visual code that made
certain images stick. Wilma's next
question was logical. If there's a code
for these faces, does it also exist for
art?
To find out, she visited the Art
Institute of Chicago, one of the largest
and most prestigious museums in the
world. She ran an experiment. She
recruited volunteers and gave them a
simple instruction. Go explore the
American Art Wing. Look at whatever you
want. Talk to your friends. Take as long
as you like.
Just make sure you walk through the
whole gallery. When they were done, she
sat them down on a bench outside and
gave them a surprise quiz on their
phones. She showed them paintings from
the exhibit mixed in with similar
paintings they hadn't seen. And she
asked,
"Do you remember this painting?"
Now, think about the variables here.
Some people love abstract art. Some love
portraits. Some people might have spent
10 minutes staring at a landscape while
others walked right past it. Surely,
their memories would be totally
different. What we found was that
actually there were still some pieces of
art that everyone remembered and some
pieces of art that everyone forgot. And
this was surprising to us cuz you would
think when you visit a museum, you're
really motivated to remember everything.
It's it's like an important valuable
experience for you. But even so, there
were some that people remembered and
some that people forgot. Okay, you're
asking,
what was it?
What is the formula for memorability?
Wilma found that size mattered. Bigger
paintings were more memorable. Okay,
that seems obvious. Context mattered.
Paintings in the more modern, spacious
wing of the gallery were remembered
better than those in the cluttered,
traditional rooms. Less competition for
your attention, maybe. But, here's the
kicker. She tested for beauty. She
tested for emotion. She tested for
colorfulness. None of those things
predicted memorability. You could have a
heartbreakingly beautiful painting, and
people would forget it 5 minutes later.
You could have a weird, jarring,
abstract piece, and it would stick. The
stickiness had to do with some
mysterious arrangement of the pieces
that appealed to the brain. But, what
was it? Now,
the human brain has billions of neurons.
Between them, they make trillions of
connections. Everything you think, you
feel, you know, it's all there in an
incredibly complex network. Somewhere in
there is the answer to the puzzle of
memorability. We might not be able to
pinpoint today exactly what's happening
in this network, but Wilma realized she
could do something that was nearly as
good. What if you took pictures of
ordinary people, like the ones Wilma
showed her volunteers in that early
study. You ask an AI to make a guess
about how memorable the first face is
going to be. It makes a random guess. If
it guessed the face was memorable, and
humans also find the face memorable, you
tell the AI,
"Good job. Keep doing what you're doing.
Strengthen the connections you used to
make this guess." If it guesses a face
was memorable, but humans think it
isn't, you tell the AI, "You got that
wrong. Whatever connections you used to
make that guess,
weaken them." Do this often enough, over
and over again, and eventually, the AI
will start to learn the secret patterns
that humans are using to determine
whether something is memorable. What
you've done, of course, is you've built
an AI model for memorability. You still
don't understand what's happening inside
the human brain, and you might not
understand everything that's happening
inside the AI, but now you can use the
AI model to make predictions about how
memorable a new face is going to be. If
the AI has learned well, it will tell
you whether humans will find a face
memorable. Wilma and her team built an
artificial intelligence model to do just
this. They called it ResMem.
You can upload a picture and it'll tell
you how memorable that picture is. So,
like one means 100% of people remember
it while zero means no one will remember
it. They trained this AI on regular
photographs, faces, scenes, everyday
objects. They didn't train it on art
history. This AI knew nothing about
Picasso. It didn't know who Van Gogh is.
It has no idea what a masterpiece is
supposed to look like. Wilma put the AI
to the ultimate test. She took the
paintings from the Art Institute study
and fed them into ResMem. And she asked,
"Is this painting memorable?" Some of
these paintings were famous works, the
ones printed mugs and tote bags. Others
were obscure works by the same artists
or from the same era that never became
famous. The result was staggering. When
asked which paintings were going to be
more memorable, the AI tended to pick
the paintings that humans considered
masterpieces. And what we were surprised
to see was that ResMem predicted that
famous pieces were more memorable than
non-famous pieces.
Think about what this means. American
Gothic isn't just famous because critics
liked it and a bunch of humans behaved
like sheep and followed them. It isn't
just famous because it captures
something about the American spirit.
It's famous because Grant Wood happened
to arrange the visual information in a
way that hacked the human brain. He
created an image that was cognitively
sticky. The AI, blind to culture and
history, was identifying masterpieces by
looking at the pixels. It seemed to be
identifying the visual hook that makes a
painting turn into a memory. And that
memory turn into fame. So, does this
mean that art is just an algorithm? That
we can paint by numbers to create the
next Mona Lisa?
Not exactly. Res nom can tell you if an
image is memorable, but it cannot tell
you if it has meaning.
A photo of a car crash might be highly
memorable, but you wouldn't want it
hanging over your sofa. But this
research does challenge the romantic
idea that art is mysterious or purely
subjective. It suggests that there are
deep, ancient currents in our brains
that dictate which images make a lasting
impression. There is a formula for
masterpieces.
I need to mention one final, profound
application for this very nascent
technology. It goes beyond art. It
speaks to the very fragility of the
human mind. While healthy brains tend to
remember similar images, people
suffering from early cognitive decline,
like Alzheimer's disease, start to
diverge from healthy people when it
comes to identifying memorable images.
We published a study a few years ago
where we found that there are some
special images that are memorable to
healthy people, but forgettable if
you're in the early stages of
Alzheimer's disease. Researchers might
one day use these images like canaries
in a coal mine. If people remember
certain images, but your friend forgets
them, it could be a warning sign that
something is wrong in her brain. We
often feel that our memories are a
recording of our lives, but Wilma
Bainbridge's work suggests that what we
remember and what we forget are shaped
by our own histories and preferences and
knowledge. Whether it's the false memory
of a monocle on the Monopoly Man or the
enduring fame of a Van Gogh
self-portrait, our minds are constantly
curating our reality based on rules we
are only just beginning to understand.
So the next time you create something, a
painting, a photograph, even a
presentation for work, remember you are
not just fighting for attention. You are
fighting to be remembered in the brains
of other people. And yes, the fight is
rigged.
But at least now you know something
about the rules. If you want to test
your own creations or just see how your
memory stacks up against the machine,
Wilma Bainbridge has made the ResMem
tool public. You can check it out at
this link. If you like this video,
please check out the Hidden Brain
podcast on Apple, Spotify, or your
favorite audio podcast player. I'll be
back soon with more ideas about the
hidden currents inside your head. I'm
Shankar Vedantam.
See you soon.